I wear three hats on any given movie
sometimes I wear one sometimes I wear
two maybe drive around wore 3 so
supervising sound editor is the person
that's responsible of running the team
of other sound editors and I kind of had
two roles one it is to the producer to
make sure I bring it in on budget unless
something comes along that the goal
posts a change and I need to reevaluate
the budget and then also to the director
to make sure that he or she there
realization of what they're looking for
with the soundtrack comes to a fruition
that's at the very least and hopefully
more than that I push it on and and show
them things that perhaps they hadn't
thought of before so that's the
supervising sound editor the sound
designer is a person who comes up with
hopefully you new and unique sounds
whether it's spaceships or bushes or
crazy sounds that you don't normally
think of and then as the real recording
mixer I'm sitting on that nice big long
mixing desk with lots of faders pushing
them up and down and balancing the
dialogue with the music with the effects
with the Foley well with baby driver I
come on board much earlier than I
normally do someone like myself as
either the sound designer or the
supervising sound editor normally comes
on board after the director's cut which
is around 10 weeks but because of my
relationship with Edgar and the fact
we've done five movies together now I
come on board quite early I think I came
on board week three of the director's
cut so he's he's only just kind of
started assembling the movie together
after the shoot at that point the
director is definitely the most
important the most kind of frequent
collaborator with regards to everything
there's the picture editors as well but
as I say with Edgar he likes to have me
in the room next door to his picture
cutting room so he'll literally finish a
sequence give me a call I come in watch
the sequence we'll have a discussion
about it and then I go into my room
start working on it come up with some
ideas and then he comes in and has a
listen and says yeah I like that carry
on
thread or that's not quite right so with
Edgar it's definitely a so it's a more
cohesive process because I'm literally
in that in the room next door team yeah
having long-term collaborators is
definitely more fruitful it breeds
environment of creativity and it's like
you're not afraid to make suggestions
that are probably crazy and stupid and I
mean not nicely stupid you know if you
if you work in it just being on a date
with someone for the first time if you
go on a date with someone for the first
time you're kind of probably trying to
convey a certain image of yourself that
you know is the nicest possible image
but if you have a long-term but with you
with your wife you can you know you're
just yourself and you say things that
you know are a bit crazy sometimes but
they're the truth so yeah acres a very
smart director he's got long-term
collaborations between the picture
editors and his composer and his DOP and
his production designer so that breeds a
fertile ground for creativity I think I
mean every single sequence in the movie
had was a challenge because of the whole
dual twofold we wanted to convey the
soundscape through baby's perspective so
doing things that are very
non-conventional like if baby pulls out
his right ear but we throw the music
onto the left-hand side of the mix for
sometimes a whole scene which is very
unconventional and it was more a
question of cracking little puzzles like
how do you syncopate police sirens over
a three-minute sequence and make them
sound realistic and make them sound
musical so I like to think that maybe
driver is it's a bit of a 3d aural
puzzle that we had to crack and each
sequence has its own set of challenges
working without that that set of music
was great I mean it was a bit of a
challenge to mix it because one thinks
that Barry White's
lush and beautiful which it does but if
you put it up on in a cinema environment
and set of speakers it actually doesn't
sound as great as you would hope it
would so you've got to kind of do a
remastering process but if there's ever
a movie that you're not constantly
tapping your toes - its baby driver
because it's just a great selection a
wide selection of you know great music I
always wanted to get and get into sound
I am from having a Sony cassette walkman
and listening to it in bed and go to
sleep listening to music I used to tape
the top 40 with Tommy Vance on Radio 1
and do kind of pause button editing and
then I saw a documentary which was Ben
Burtt on Star Wars explaining how he
came up with the sounds of the TIE
fighters and she back her and the
blasters and so I knew I wanted to get
into sound and I studied at the school
of audio engineering for a year because
I thought I wanted to get into music
production and I kind of fell in to the
TV and and film side so which I'm glad
for for obvious reasons but yeah
perseverance working hard and treating
people with respect around you and who
work for you I've never been on set I
think I've been on set once in my 25
years of doing this I get involved with
questions and information and you know
because producer would call me to say
we're doing this set up tomorrow how
would you like it but I never go on set
which is a shame because it's there's
that's one end of the spectrum and I'm
this end of the spectrum and never the
twain shall meet but I started off doing
TV stuff and things like spooks for
kudos and life on Mars we did when I had
my company and then I used to split
between doing TV and feature films and
then 10 11 years ago I decided to
concentrate purely on feature films so
that's what I do now movies I would
definitely give a direct message to
anybody who's looking to chase their
dreams I am the embodiment that you can
do it I
I'm from a very small town in Suffolk
and when I went to see my careers
officer and they said tell me anything
you want to do and I'll try and make it
work and I said I want to get into sound
and he said well that's great he said
but I can offer you a job at the local
bank if you liked this work experience
and I decided I didn't want to do that
and I just wanted to push through so
keep out at key tipping away
everything's possible it's a little bit
of luck it's talent and it is it just
don't stop chasing your dreams
you